we had t-pain on the podcast and he was
talking about how he had made like 40
million dollars and then just blown
through it and got to a point where he
could not afford a whopper at burger
king
and uh
and then he came and then he came back
you know like
i wondered i don't know what the
particulars are of your financial
situation but
it sounded like all of that talk around
the g wagon was like
the the remainder of the 30 000 needed
to pay it off then it just wasn't there
yeah and so it's like it kind of gave me
the impression that you had been like
on fire just making money like crazy and
then all of a sudden like just slowed
down and that went away like pretty
quick yeah well like uh uh and i'm very
open to talk um talking about my
financial situation right now
no i'm not broke you know what i mean i
support my dad i support my mom i bought
my mom a house in temecula
uh paid full in cash i bought my dad a
house in uh corona very close to each
other
um i did that um
there was a video where you did say that
you were broke
really oh no no that video was satire
because i was at uh
the the guy who created the app wish
uh peter he's a good friend of me he's
like a billionaire and that that was
just i i can't believe people didn't
pick that that was satire because i'm
walking through a mansion like while i'm
doing it and then showing like the
venador and then the golf course but i
think the clip that we saw it's it was
like you were like oh whatever brand
deal take it you know let's do the brand
new there's a day in the life of the no
jumper podcast yeah two take the brand
whatever whatever the brains well if it
was during the no jumper time i
definitely wasn't broke then
and now yo i mean whatever i mean i
think broke is a subject suggestion yeah
yeah okay i'll say this from when from
2018 when i signed my deal i'm nowhere
near that rich
as of now but i am very
not like i'm far from broke so you're
dude you're comfortable i'm comfortable
and i'm not trying to put you on the
spot no no you're good i just uh you
know having had that conversation with
t-pain
and then
kind of looking at what at what your
story
has seemed like over the last couple of
years i just feel like
if you're now in the position where
you're going back on tour and you're
selling tickets well it's like you kind
of have a rebirth yeah and so now
like
i
i want to think that you're gonna take
uh have a different attitude about the
money that you earn and and how you
manage your opportunity and i totally
agree with that and and the first step
with that uh for you know um being more
uh fiscally responsible with my money
was getting clean to have a clear mind
clarity equal is gonna make me lots of
money because this tour i'm netting is
gonna i'm gonna bring back 100k i uh you
know have a decent amount in my bank
account right now enough to still
support my parents with the groceries
and stuff uh enough to have a nice uh
you know little condo in l.a
um
and yeah and i i knew i needed to get
sober before i could start
be adulting because i feel like me
becoming an adult was stunted because i
had when i first got famous at 21 i was
still a kid and i was already addicted
coming into this stuff you know so and
but and at that point when i blew up i
had the assistance around me doing
everything for me right like so it was
hard like you know to so now since 24
i've been and now like 25 i'm learning
how to do everything on my own because
it was stunning because i had someone to
do that for me somebody did that for
right but now that i'm sober
um thank god uh and have a clear sense a
clear sense of mind
everything has been going [ __ ]
wonderful i'm on antidepressants effexor
they work wonderful for me
and yeah everything is just going so
great my girlfriend is wonderful
my friends are wonderful and they're
very supportive none of them do drugs
they smoke a little weed and uh
and drink occasionally but
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and
sky
the footage is so intense we have full
grown men passing out at almost every
city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
yeah
[Applause]